in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinhaxadion for June 30th, on which we commemorate the synaxes of
the Holy Glorious and all-lotted Twelve Apostles.
On the 30th of the month we celebrate the synaxes of the Twelve Holy Glorious and Illustrious
Apostles.
On this day, illumined by the reflected glory of the first two leaders of the Apostles,
the Church associates the other illustrious Apostles of the Lord, who form a new choir
of shining stars in the spiritual firmament.
Foundations and pillars of the Church, they are also the angels who guard the Twelve Gates
giving access to the heavenly Jerusalem.
The earliest of the people of Israel, the sons of Jacob, were twelve in number, and the
Lord also chose twelve disciples whom He made witnesses of His teaching and miracles,
whom He sent to preach the kingdom of God, and on whom He conferred the power to cast out
demons and to heal every infirmity.
After the resurrection, He sent them throughout the world to proclaim the gospel to the whole
creation, and to baptize all peoples in the name of the Father and of the Son and
of the Holy Spirit.
Just as the Son had been sent by the Father into the world for our salvation, so choosing
His disciples and gathering them together, He sent them to proclaim that the kingdom
of heaven was very near, as the Father has sent me, so I send you.
As the condition for becoming His apostles, He asked them to renounce all earthly attachments.
Provide neither gold nor silver nor brass in your purses nor script for your journey nor
two coats, neither shoes nor yet staves.
He also warned them that they would undergo tribulations and persecutions in bearing witness
to Him.
Behold, I send you forth as sheep in the midst of wolves.
You will be hated by all on account of me.
You will bear witness before governors and kings for my sake.
To bear witness to me, but when they deliver you up, take no thought how or what ye shall
speak, or what you are to say.
For it shall be given you in that same hour what ye shall speak.
For it is not ye that speak, but the Spirit of your Father which speaketh in you.
Witnesses of the resurrection of the Lord, both by their lives and their preaching, the
Holy Apostles offered themselves as a spectacle before the world, before angels and before the
human race.
Starting with St. Paul, we have become a spectacle unto the world, ill-treated, homeless,
naked, we both hunger and thirst, and endure harassment of every kind, rejected by all.
So that by their sacrifice the church might be built on the power of God and not on human
strength, today the Holy and illustrious Apostles form a harmonious choir around the first
two Apostles.
Andrew, the first called Brother of Peter, who proclaimed the gospel in the coastal regions
of Bethinia, Pontus, and Armenia, returning by way of Pontus and Byzantium, he traveled
as far as Greece where he was crucified at Patras in Achaea.
James, the son of Zebedee, who witnessed to the resurrection throughout the whole of Judea,
he perished by the sword on the orders of King Herod Agrippa, who was jealous of his
renown.
John the Theologian, the brother of James, who rested on the Lord's breast.
After having proclaimed Christ in the province of Asia, he was exiled to Patmos on the orders
of Domitian, where he wrote the gospel and the apocalypse.
He finally returned to Ephesus, where he fell asleep in peace at a great age.
Philip, who came from Bethsida in Galilee like Peter and Andrew, he proclaimed the good news
in the province of Asia and in the region of Yerapulis in Fridia, in the company of his sister
Mariamne and of Saint Bartholomew, he died in Yerapulis being crucified by the pagans.
Thomas, also called Didymus, who spread the gospel among the Parthians, Meeds, and Persians,
and the inhabitants of India.
He was pierced to death by pagan lances.
Bartholomew preached in Lydia and in Misia, along with the Apostle Philip.
After the death of the latter, he continued his mission in Arabia Felix, now North Yemen,
in Persia, and in India, and finished his course in Armenia, where he was crucified
in Albanapulis, or Urbanapulis.
His body was placed in a lead box and thrown into the sea, but was later recovered in Sicily.
Matthew, the publican, formerly called Levi, was the brother of James the son of Alphius.
After having written his gospel, he left on a mission to the Parthenians.
It is said that he was burned alive in Yerapulis, on the banks of the Euphrates.
James, the son of Alphius, proclaimed Christ in Gaza, and in and around the Leltheriopolis.
He was crucified in the town of Ostrasin in Egypt.
Simon the zealot, from Cana and Galilee, who is also called Nathaniel in the Gospel
of John, proclaimed the good news in Mauritania, in North Africa.
It is said that he then left for Great Britain, where he was crucified.
Jude, a kinsman of the Lord, also called Thaddeus, and Levi by Saint Matthew, departed on
a mission to Mesopotamia and finished his days in the region near Mount Ararat, where he
was hanged and pierced with arrows by pagans.
Matthias was added to the number of the apostles after the ascension to replace Judas the traitor.
He preached the gospel in Ethiopia where he gave his soul into God's hands after suffering
numerous tortures at the hands of the pagans.
It is the custom to associate the holy evangelists with these blessed apostles, Mark, a spiritual
son of Saint Peter, who evangelized Alexandria and the Pentopolis, and who suffered martyrdom
by being crushed under the weight of a rock.
Luke, the physician, and first iconographer, who after having accompanied Saint Paul on his
journeys, wrote his gospel under the apostles' influence.
Finally, settling in Thebes in Boatia, he died there in peace at the age of 84.
It is on the testimony of these holy apostles whose sound is gone out into all lands in order
to proclaim the reality of Christ's resurrection that the church has been built.
If they occupy the first place in the assembly of the saints, it is precisely because detaching
themselves from everything else in order to follow the Lord, they became His perfect imitators
and proclaimed to all, be ye followers of us, just as we are of Him.
Once the generation of those who had known the Lord during His earthly life had passed,
the Apostolic ministry did not end, but as Saint Paul testifies, was transmitted to all those
who have beheld the resurrection of Christ through the illumination of the Holy Spirit.
The grace of the Apostolic Charisma is not limited to the oral proclamation of the good news,
but is shared by all the saints who have contributed to the building up of the church through their
witness to the resurrection.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.